what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about one of the most
intelligent characters in boku no hero
and a character with one of the craziest
most game-changing quirks in the entire
series I am of course referring to me ty
Sasaki better known as sir Knight i he
is the former sidekick of all might the
mentor of media Takata and the person
who accepted deku into his hero office
for the work-study program but only
after one of the most interesting job
interviews of all time in this video I
will be breaking down everything you
need to know about sir Knight AI and the
unique properties of his quirk which is
called foresight before we get into it I
want to give a huge thank you to raid
shadow legends for sponsoring this video
raid shadow Legends is a new collection
RPG game that has just blown up recently
with almost 15 million downloads in the
last six months I really love the epic
dark fantasy setting the great graphics
strategic gameplay huge boss fights
immersive storylines and the over 400
champions for you to collect and
personally customize you can assemble a
team from 16 heroic factions discover 13
spectacular locations raid with friends
in a clan or claim glory for yourself in
the PvP arena and best of all raid is
free-to-play just click the link in the
description and check it out for
yourself the game is constantly adding
cool new features such as the multi
battle Auto mode which allows you to set
battles to run in Auto mode while you go
do something else
it lets you spend less time grinding and
more time doing the fun stuff the weekly
tournaments and events allow you to win
extra prizes every week by fighting in
the arena running special dungeons or
just leveling up your heroes and some
brand new champions have just been
introduced including the lovely and
creepy madam Sarris from the dark elves
vac ship you have to check this out for
yourself just go to the video
description click on the special links
and you will get 50,000 silver and a
free epic champion as part of the new
player program to start your journey
heads up this video will cover in four
about sir nite ize backstory personality
and quirk however I will not be spoiling
what happens in the story itself after
sir Knight I has introduced and I will
not be spoiling the ending of the arcs
that will be covered in season four of
the anime if you are okay with that then
by all means proceed with the video when
we first meet sir Knight I he seems like
an extremely serious and Stern man with
a glaring look in his eye he appears to
be the epitome of the serious Japanese
salaryman but we quickly learned that
everything is not quite as it seems with
Knight I it turns out that night I has
some very unorthodox means of running
his zero office and these unusual
methods extend to how he treats his
sidekicks and to how he interviews
potential applicants for the work-study
program
nevertheless sir nite ize methods appear
to be highly effective as is evident
from his successful mentorship of medial
Takata media was not always the
exceptional student that he is today in
fact in his first year at UA
media is said to have been a bit of an
underachiever but thanks to Sir night
eyes mentorship miryo completely
transformed himself and he quickly
became one of the strongest and most
successful hero students in UA as Miriah
reveals to Deku right before his
interview despite appearing to be Stern
and serious on the outside sir Knight I
actually values humor very highly and he
requires people to make him laugh before
he will show them respect
that is why media advises Deku to try
and makes her Knight I laugh but that
just makes Decker even more nervous for
the actual interview the reason why sir
Knight I values humor so highly stems
from his admiration for all might as the
symbol of peace
Knight I was always a massive fan of all
might a true all my otaku just like Deku
and he eventually became all my sidekick
after persistently pestering all my to
accept him at the time all might was not
interested in taking on a sidekick but
night I was so stubborn that all might
eventually relented with that said sir
Knight I believes that the ability to
smile in the face of hardship and the
ability to make other people laugh and
smile is absolutely crucial for a
successful hero and especially for the
one hero who is considered to be the
very
full of peace this is why night I
admired all might so greatly almighty
was always able to keep smiling no
matter how hard of a challenge he was
facing and this is exactly what put the
general populace at ease the people knew
that no matter what happens everything
would be okay because all might would be
there with a smile on his face ready to
save them from villains accidents
natural disasters and just about
anything that life could throw at them
like many other people sir Knight I was
worried that after all meit's retirement
no one would be able to step in and fill
all my shoes certainly someone like
endeavor despite being a really strong
hero does not possess the type of
uplifting and friendly personality that
can put everyone around him at ease this
is why night I wanted me do toget uh to
become all my successor and the
inheritor of one for all media also has
that same ability to overcome even the
hardest challenges while maintaining a
positive outlook and a smile on his face
just like all might me do is powerful
enough to instill fear into villains and
cheery and positive enough to instill
hope into civilians because of his
belief that media should have been all
my successor sir Knight I is initially
skeptical about Deku and he is slow to
warm up to him at this point it is worth
mentioning why exactly sir Knight I
stopped being on my sidekick for those
of you who might be wondering after all
my defeated all-4-one the previous time
about six years earlier Almighty was
severely injured but despite being
injured all might insisted that he
should still keep being a hero as usual
however sir Knight I disagreed Knight I
believe that all might should retire and
pick a successor because all my injuries
were so severe that they could result in
all my dying in battle but all might
refuse to retire believing that if he
retired now before preparing a true
successor the general populace would
become uneasy and an era of fear and
uncertainty would ensue because he
didn't want to have any part in his
friends reckless behavior sir Knight I
decided to stop being all my sidekick
and he opened his own hero office
instead now let's talk about sir Knight
ice quirk because part of the reason why
night I was so sure that all my children
tyre is directly related to the nature
of his quirk the quirk
foresight gives its user the ability to
see into the future of a specific person
if he touches a person and makes eye
contact with them Sir Knight I can see
what is going to happen to that person
for one hour in great detail needless to
say this is an incredibly powerful quirk
as it allows night eye to predict the
moves of his opponents or to find out
information about his targets that they
never would have disclosed otherwise
such as for example the location of
their secret hideout sir Knight I can
only use this ability once every 24
hours so that is a major limitation and
the way that sir Knight I see someone's
future is very specific he sees all the
events from a third-person perspective
as if looking through a roll of film
this means that he doesn't hear any
sounds or smell any smells his foresight
works solely on the basis of his visual
senses another important aspect of
foresight is that beyond being able to
tell very precisely what a person will
do within the next hour night I squirt
also allows him to gain less specific
glimpses into a person's more distant
future so he might have glimpses of
events that are going to happen months
or even years from now although he does
not know the exact date or the exact
circumstances of how the events will
unfold another major reason why sir
Knight I wanted all my to retire was the
fact that after all mites fight with all
for one night I used his foresight to
look into all mites more distant future
when he did this he saw that 6 or 7
years into the future all might we'll
meet a horrible end at the hands of an
unspecified villain Knight I calls all
mites death too gruesome to describe and
because all of nite ize predictions have
always come true so far he begs all my
to do his best to change his fate by
retiring and staying out of harm's way
but of course we know that all might
refused and the two friends went their
separate ways
although they still maintained an
enormous level respect for each other
because his quirk allows him to see
future events that can be tragic such as
all mites apparent and demise sir Knight
AI is often hesitant about using his
quirk at all he doesn't want to see
tragic events that he cannot possibly
stop and then have to live with that
terrible knowledge but the real question
is is the future that sir Knight I see
is inevitable
or is it only inevitable if he accepts
that this is the way it is perhaps the
future that he sees was inevitable
before but the very act of him seeing it
means that something could be changed
the fact that he now has knowledge of
future events that no one else possesses
could mean that there is some hope in
changing them after all when he looks
into the future he is seeing the
original timeline but perhaps he and the
people around him can create a new
timeline by making changes in the
present in order to affect the future
beyond his quirk sir nice physical
weapon of choice are stamped seals that
wave 5 kilograms each and which he
throws at his opponents as projectiles
this choice of weapons is definitely in
line with nite ize Japanese salaryman
persona and in general sir tonight I
offers a really cool juxtaposition
between conformity and quirkiness if
you'll pardon to play on words so let me
know what you guys think
do you like sir Knight I as a character
and what do you think of his quirk feel
free to share your thoughts down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more boku no hero
content right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications the only way to
make sure that YouTube will actually
notify you is to click the option to
turn on all notifications you could also
check me out on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar there I will post all the
latest news and updates on MHA including
season 4 of the anime don't forget to
check out our generous sponsor raid
shadow legends it's free just click the
link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]